thông kế của bộ y tế trong năm tặng đầu năm 2020, cả nước đã vi nhận
gần 2018 gà mắc sốt suất viết đèn ngoài và đã có năm ca tử vòng
tải các tình thành phố. Hình miền bắc đã vào 1 năm ấm.
Môn nhiều, là thời điểm bắt đầu của sịch sốt suất viết làan dọc.
Như tình, thành phố đã vi nhận số cà mắc sốt suất viết ra tăng,
dự báo trong thời gian tối, số mắc có thể tiếp tục tăng rồi đã bắt đầu
bước vào các thẳng cao điểm của bệnh hàng năm.
Tại khu vực phía năm hiện đăng là cao điểm của sịch mạnh sốt viết khi số cà mắc,
số cà nạ, số số suất viết tăng lên.
Đăng chú ý, số cà mắc sốt suất viết mới gây nhận hàng chăm cà mắc
sốt suất viết mới tần. Tất chung cao tại một số khu vực có nhiều khu công nghiệp lớn,
theo cuộc phòng mạnh, bộ y tế, hình sịch sốt viết sĩnh biển khá phức tạp sợ với trước đây.
Nếu chương đầy chu kỳ dịch bùng phát với số cà mắc cao tửa ngách nhau khoảng năm năm,
thì hình chu kỳ này chỉ khoảng 2 năm.
Vânih không có thời điểm nào dịch sốt suất viết nừng lại,
tất cả các tình đều quyết, không có tình nào là không có dịch.
Chức hi bắt đầu vào dạng cao điểm dịch sốt viết,
bộ y tế đề nghị các địa phương đầy mạnh công tác chuyến thông đừng cao nhận thức của người dân để chú đồng phòng chống,
chẳng lời lan.
Tăng kương các địa pháp dịch loang quan, bộ y phương mỗi tại các hộ ra điện.
Ngành y tế cũng đầy mạnh các hòa động liên quan đến việc phát hiện sớm các ca mắc,
chỉ việc các hù vực sau định các địa nắm về sốt viết đề tình các định pháp ngăn chẳng tự giống.
Tự giả.
Vyệt chú đồng kiểm soát suất phát hiện được các hùa có nghĩa cơ cao, ngăn dịch loy làan dọc.